Four weeks straight,
my toddlers have been asking me for chicken nuggets and fries.
They usually don't request a lot,
so I decided to make them exactly that today.
I started by grinding up my chicken
and then seasoning it with onion and garlic powder,
paprika and salt. I formed them into little nugget shapes
and put them on a Parchment paper lined baking tray
before popping them in the freezer for about 30 minutes.
In the meantime,
I washed my potatoes and sliced them up into matchsticks.
Repeated that with all of my potatoes
before placing them into ice cold water
and let that sit while I made my ketchup.
I combined some tomato paste,
honey, vinegar, water,
salt and let that simmer until thickened before letting it cool.
Dried off all of my potatoes as best as I could
before seasoning them up and putting them on a baking tray
roast in the oven. I left them in there for about 30 to 40 minutes
and when they were almost done,
I started on the batter for my chicken nuggets.
I mix some cornstarch, flour,
seasoning and some sparkling water
my chicken nuggets and some cornstarch
and then in my batter
before frying them up until they were golden brown on both sides.
I then placed them on a wire rack and it was time to plate.
Plate it up. My chicken nuggets first,
then my fries and some of that homemade ketchup
and my kids were so Excited to have this